[Music]
in I'm innocent news didn't do it I'm
innocent dude submitted by WTF is up JK
what the [ __ ] a man is fighting a ticket
after he says the officer confused his
hashbrown Patty for a cellphone yeah not
that but this officer assumed that I was
looking at my phone on my lap as I was
driving trying to hide it from him yeah
but I was not hitting my phone I had a
kimchi staying on my short and I'll try
to scrub it out like this yeah and he
was like you were looking down at your
phone you're not time he slick or
whatever but I was like no I have a
kimchi stick right here and I'm looking
at he goes starts cracking up because
it's okay because my phone was actually
my backpack in the trunk so I don't even
have it on me homie
good for you so on yeah he was laughing
did he feel dumb oh you felt dumb were
just laughing at it cuz I guess who not
his fault
sorry wasn't the phone it was this gun
joke's on you man it was this right here
so it was the kimchi stand on my gun I
said pretty cool yeah so this guy's name
is Jason he's from Connecticut he's
fighting this ticket for distracted
driving but he is distracted driving cuz
you should be eating while you're
driving I mean what you don't have to
look at your food yeah we should but
anyway so you need to drop it illegal to
eat well you can't do anything but
Charlie yeah then drive no I love eating
and rice but why the [ __ ] did I get the
Tesla then because I can drive also it's
like it's one of those rules were like
unless you get caught and pulled over
then you don't really get the thing Tim
so the drive throughs they're trying to
get us caught and that's problem you
goes through the drive-through and then
sits in the parking lot or maybe you
take it home Tyko you're like oh you hit
the passenger can eat or feet I'll
sometimes well what if I'm driving cuz
sometimes gia will feed me while I'm
trying it's ok still ok
wait it says there is no
California law explicitly prohibiting
eating while driving aa Ala for years
don't know is that in you or did my mom
just like all we drive out here homie
it's a it's a part of distracted driving
so like if you're just in your food and
you're having like this then that's
different but like yeah technically
there isn't a law specifically stating
out you cannot eat a french fries mom
likes me because then she also said that
at night you can't drive with your light
on yeah inside your she told me that
your mom's a liar would they did but
Joe's right police can type that for the
tractor driving yeah if he wants to be a
dick I mean they can cite you for a
bunch of [ __ ] I'd if I get pulled over
I'm [ __ ] when I get McDonald's I open
like whatever sandwich I have the box
yeah I have my McNuggets sauce set up in
the corner and I open packets of ketchup
so there's no definitely it's a full on
setup meal here right
but I also house new driveways I've seen
the middle console with the Nugget box
with the sauce it fits like perfectly in
there sometimes you open it up with the
sauce and the lid sometimes I don't like
driving and eating all the fries because
your hands get greasy and you have to
touch the wheel ya know do you need one
hand for driving one hand for booting
sometimes I need my both hands bro I
bought this [ __ ] it was the dumbest [ __ ]
I ever buy only used it one time just to
prove a point that's like it was so
stupid but it's a tray it's a that and
the handle part goes into your cup
holder so it's like it fits securely
into your cup holder and then it comes
up and there's a tray you can put your
face in that [ __ ] what's that it does
that chick-fil-a I don't know what it
was but it's like a box that goes on top
of your food I don't know this was
literally like a plastic [ __ ] tray
that I ordered online because I saw it
on tumblr and then I ordered it and like
Rick and [ __ ] were like this is so
stupid I'm like guys it's gonna come in
handy and there's like no you're never
gonna use that I was like oh yeah I pull
it one day I had the [ __ ] thing in
there we just bought some Donnelly huh
Hey look who's eating and driving really
easily
I never used it again you took a sharp
turn it spilled anything and I crashed
that's true because it should be against
the law to not eat fries after 10
seconds or else off the drive-through as
the bag is being pulled to you you go
thank you
like that and then you drive you gotta
eat like this I don't want to warmish
soggy fries yeah that's so [ __ ] weird
dude
yeah soggy fries it's nice cold ranch a
Thousand Islands well you could had all
of my soggy fries yeah that's why we're
good friends cuz she loves the crispy
one and then I'll pick out the soggy one
how about just like fresh fries
I like all fries except for the one
where no one starts to get cold and you
bite into a gentle powder on the inside
that's the only what I don't like do
y'all like the like fatter fries better
or skinny fries better Oh depends that
depends I like that Shake Shack well
done fries dude I haven't done that yet
[ __ ] that's elementary school fries
she's so good Oh cuz I like the squiggly
yeah yeah I like them you know it's like
elementary because it's elementary
namely fries you see them and I'm like
it's gonna taste like what it's not what
the jack-in-the-box fries are like
squiggly oh no Jaguars curly fries are
these are the ones that are like like
the crisp cut no no Chris cred is the
the waffle fries the freezer fries yeah
those are just as good two men crinkle
fries like paintball fried pickle taste
inside of the fry the better that's why
I like fat fries smoggy fries that's
what you like those [ __ ] steak fries
soggy as [ __ ] all the time I mean man oh
like five guys fries ever ever girl you
need to had their fries man we thought
we saw fries I wasn't impressed with
five guys no at all no not none of it it
just tastes like a regular burger is
that what we ate it in [ __ ] here like
pops brings ish yeah did you you can add
a bunch of [ __ ] to it though I did I got
whatever the supposed to be the poster
you know as a Californian I do have to
say this just because recently I did
have Shake Shack
Shake Shack is better than
I agree Oh reason why I say this is
because this is this is what happens
Shake Shack the reason why Shake Shack I
think to most people isn't bit better
than in and out is simply based on the
fact that Shake Shack is [ __ ]
expensive so it makes their makes them
go I can't believe like oh is it really
worth it if Shake Shack was the same
prices in and out you would be going to
shake [ __ ] yeah well yeah all I could
think about is the quality ingredients
because because I I think I had Shake
Shack when I was broke as [ __ ] and then
when I'm mad at it so I ate it recently
again and I was like well ah this is a
better burger
it is never even tried it yet no oh my
god we have two [ __ ] girls y'all
never been no by the way - in and out is
[ __ ] delicious but Shake Shack is an
in-n-out burger that's elevated oh look
man so I argue both ways because you
know I'm right or die in an hour yeah I
love it and it not always has a place in
my heart not me and whatever people
whenever people don't like in and out I
always say no y'all gotta order like
this y'all gotta add your chopped
chilies and get an animal style all that
[ __ ] right but like but okay look not
gonna lie
when I go to Chez Shack and I take
advice from stay exact I'm like ah but
I'm the same way in and out so I always
argued the money point right what's like
in and out it's cheap it's quick and for
what you're getting it's such good
quality right if dad knew closer shake
shake shake it's like dammit like a
restaurant though because you get all
these options they do hot dogs
milkshakes all this others I mean in an
hour does too but shakes out there's a
lot of [ __ ] right so I feel like it's
almost other level you're arguing it has
to taste the quality and quiet no let's
see this is what you see so I say that
too so the biggest difference is you
can't compare it or not to Shake Shack
because in and out is a comparison to
fast-food burgers Shake Shack is not
fast food right so everyone compares
them cuz it now is a fast-food burger
it's not in the same realm I thought it
wasn't considered fast food because
they're cooking it yeah but when you're
consider it so yes but then I think when
you're considering the two it's not fair
to consider one with the other cuz the
price point is already different like if
you could put the price point for both
at the exact same I feel like it would
probably be pretty good right
strikethrough the Shake Shack because
they don't know it'll have direct well
okay okay cuz like the technical term
for fast food is the food is already
like pre-made and it's sitting there and
it's in a warmer or whatever not enough
any now isn't considered fast food but
because it has a fast food format fat
has drive-thru and has fast food prices
people compare it with Carl's jr. and
McDonald and they compare shake shagging
in and out because you know in and out
it's like west coast only Shake Shack
you could only get on the East Coast
originally and then they just started
popping up what's the word fast casual I
think that's the word no casual because
Shake Shack does the burger bleed on you
know because it's it's it's a griddled
patty right so they get a feed on a
flattop and they [ __ ] make sure that
[ __ ] has as brown as Possible's crispy
all over Oh I mean definitely in and out
has that too but they [ __ ] smash is a
smash burger I like I like that I like
that because it has a crush a fight yeah
everywhere and their potato bread it's
like so soft and it's like Hawaiian
bread Oh which is a Shake Shack combo so
let's say if you get fries a Shake Shack
burger and a drink that'll be like 16 17
bucks you're paying like 30 bucks for
two people yes the price yeah so it
anounced seven bucks
yeah it's double and then so that's the
same prices as I grow them all which is
like my favorite burger place see that's
what we should be comparing Shake Shack
to is more like a look like a
mom-and-pop burger joint right yeah but
because it's a chain they compare that
to in and out and if you don't need me
if you don't mean Shake Shack has this
some impossible one it knowable not only
that they have this on Portobello cheese
fried thing oh it's good - it's so fun I
do not bite into a burger and there's
blood coming out of my mouth shakes I
can do that for you I think you can ask
make being cells so unappetizing with
everything you're the living version of
a Chinese menu dude yeah oxtail but soup
chuckle it's alright so this story here
with the guy the distracted driving
thing oh yeah don't have lips yeah I'm
trying to hear the story so um the
ticket is $300 but he's fighting it in
court and he has spent already about a
thousand dollars in legal aid oh yeah
this is a pride thing because he was
just like I wasn't on my phone there's
phone records proving that I wasn't on
my phone cuz the cop says like he saw
him with like talking on the phone like
this and with the screen illuminated but
it was just the white light it was just
a glow and hash brown yeah yeah at the
beautiful oil on that nice try kimchi
stain cop so is he what what happen so I
mean they they're not in heaven the
judge hasn't announced his verdict yeah
oh my lord
okay our wins I mean he's gonna win
because all he has to get is the the
cell phone thing and the time that the
cop said lost because the tickets 300
bucks he's already spent a thousand at
this not about that yep he's to press
the pound well at least you won't have a
point on his driving record and maybe he
will save money in the long run and
maybe the cop was a dick and he really
wants to just be like hey you idiot I
was right you were wrong ha no no I'm
pretty [ __ ] petty though cuz on the
way back to Sacramento
I forgot what city was Bill's like a
couple hours out and I got a ticket and
you have to go could just to take it all
the way over there yeah yes what
[ __ ] I drove two hours back
there's the contested my cop buddy gave
me the lowdown
he's like CHP guys so because they're
traffic violation only based you got to
be really careful around them if you got
ten roll down your windows have your
brake lights whatever fix all that stuff
city cops they're like half and half
sheriff can only try to catch drug
dealers rapists and murderers
hmm so when the cop wouldn't like you
feel you've got a California roll a stop
sign and you see a cop and go [ __ ] since
we're gonna pull me over and he does it
he's probably Sheriff because he's like
I don't give a [ __ ] about that right
find real criminals yeah
the CHP don't do any and they're the
ones that'll chase you from city to city
to city like you could you can have a
broken taillight and you just try to
evade them though the ones I'll chase
you some cities in it that's true I had
a CHP chase me all the way down for
miles and mile
really and then they let me go why don't
you stop they didn't have their sirens
on other this monitor here we were just
seeing yeah like this when I first got
my Jaguar obviously if you stole that
she had Asian boy
[Music]